có gì sân đi, panel Z, as a key pillar.
Cần đưa năng gợp cho thành một chục của thật thách chính cho quan hệ ASEAN Nga.
Tìm đang chơi đầu tiêu và thật giữa ASEAN và Nga còn rất lớn.
Dết là trong phát triển năng lượng xa kiếp.
ASEAN, Hí đô Xen, nghị gióng ngoài khuy, có ngại thích kiệ Năng lượng.
Thúc đẩy hật thách về công nghệ đổi mới sáng thạo và chuyện đủ số.
Đây là một trong những thứ thật thách quan chọt giữa ASEAN và Nga trong ra đoạn tới.
Lênh yên ASEAN, Hẳng Túc đẩy các chương trình hợp tóc đổi mới, hỗ trợ xuống nghiệp công nghệ và xuống nghiệp chè.
Hình thành hệ xin thái đổi mới sáng thạo năng gợp.
Cái đổi trạc trạc cộng đồng xuống nghiệp, hai bây giờ có mùi này tý dạy.